on Monday scientists announced the
completion of the human genome sequence
mapping the three billion letters that
make up human DNA this latest advance
comes 50 years after biologist James
Watson and Francis Crick proposed the
double helix structure for DNA next on
book TV dr. Watson discusses the new
findings as well as his new book DNA the
secret of life it's 45 minutes good
evening I'm k Jameson from the
department of psychiatry at Johns
Hopkins and I am absolutely delighted to
be able to introduce dr. James Watson
from Cold Spring Harbor Laboratory for
since the 28th of februari this year and
probably before that there have been a
lot of celebrations about the 50th
anniversary of the discovery by Jim
Watson and Francis Crick of the
structure of the DNA of the double helix
it's been fantastic I think Jim and Liz
Watson are probably worn out completely
by all the celebrations but I'm a great
believer there's no such thing as too
much champagne and it's been a great
time for science to rally around and I
think really show in addition to
everything else the appreciation for not
only for Jim's scientific brilliance but
also for his incredible dedication for
many decades to the field of science
many many accomplishments in terms of
just sheer devotion to science in the
pursuit of knowledge yesterday when Jim
was talking at NIH he brought up the
subject of David Hume on the passions
and how important the passions were in
scientific work and and in life in terms
of curiosity and so forth and I think
that of all the people I know Jim's life
has been characterized by life of
passion and curiosity of course for the
original discovery with with creek but
also for a scientific leadership and for
with lists who is over here Liz Watson
who's
I've been married for 35 35 years
probably seems a lot longer but anyway
the two of them have not only built up
an incredible place in Cold Spring
Harbor in terms of scientific excellence
is just magnificent but they've created
a really magical place in terms of
beauty and physical beauty and
architecture and it's just been
wonderful to watch I'm here really to
introduce Jim very briefly in terms of
writing because I think Jim people focus
so much and rightfully so on his science
that he doesn't get as much credit for
his tremendous writing ability when he
wrote the molecular biology of gene it
really revolutionized the way people
thought it was just an extraordinary
book just a remarkable book and for all
of us who read the double helix whatever
stages of our intellectual and academic
training we were in I can remember
exactly where I was when I started
reading it it was that kind of book and
it's very hard I think to say how
difficult it is to write that well in a
sort of breezy manner but it's not
breezy at all and it is it's a book of
great pursuit and adventure and it's
just a fabulous book and his most recent
book DNA is a book that only Jim Watson
could have written it's a perspectives
on DNA from every imaginable point of
view so if you haven't bought at least
one or two copies do I'm delighted to
introduce dr. Watson
DNA is not going to be my last book I
have a book tentatively titled manners
for science which different stages of my
life I have a chapter on you know how to
be a writer and chapter on how to get a
Nobel Prize and they are you know how to
go to Stockholm to get it you know
there's that the week in it and ever
chapter on you know as a child in
chicago and the first sentence of the
book which really tried to with says i
was born on april six 1928 in chicago
into a family which believed in books
birds in the Democratic Party and this
was sort of summarizes the values of my
childhood my mother was a precinct
captain and the 7th ward in Chicago and
we had the elections in our house and I
went to two Democratic conventions and I
haven't changed much but I like to write
and the good sense and you know somehow
say something that in a way that's
people haven't said it before they come
out for them so DNA was written to
accompany a TV series which if PBS ever
accepts us that is a period in England
will come out in June I think late June
series and it tries to sort of say
everything you can about DNA written
with the help of a very simpatico
Englishman named andrew Berry who
is went to the school that Charles
Darwin did Shrewsbury and strong
evolutionary way looking at things which
complements my own I want to always ask
you know how did it evolve and what were
the Selective factor so and when I think
about the Human Genome Project you know
it really should really should look at
it you know people should finally
realize were products of evolution yeah
not of design from God where does
products of evolution and some of us and
you know always when we have slightly
different set of genes there's been
enough change so we can either be better
or worse you know our compliments in our
parents and so there's a great deal
spread and when I was a child I didn't
want to be believed I was determined by
my jeans I think you know people want to
believe you're free from you know what
your who your parents are but as you get
older and certainly after you have
children you you just think it's not you
it's just the jeans and your kids which
make them look there so you make this
transition and so I may sound more Jhene
oriented that I should but it's sort of
the way I feel I am sometimes someone
wants to get after me they say you know
I just believe it's only the jeans
because they called me saying you know
where you know our fate is determined
not by the stars but our James which was
more or less saying you know astrology
is crap and
and you know to the extent we're sort of
determine this by our genes of course
that's not surprising because our genes
control you know the amount of our
neurotransmitters and they must affect
our way our brain works so it's sort of
impossible to believe that we wouldn't
be controlled by our genes are trying to
select for human nature which will
somehow let us survive different forms
well you know keep us here too hungry
enough so we get food and so the book is
unabashedly I guess pro DNA as i'd like
to say the only person was unfairly been
hurt by DNA is Bill Clinton and yeah in
the sense he should have never been
asked that question you know and that
sets you know it's pretty good evidence
and so and you know no one I think has
been one person who has been hurt by
eating any genetically modified food or
in the sense work by the fact that has a
genius whereas you know lots of people
have got sick from raspberries which you
know there's some dysentery is so so
forth so you know you do get food sick
from food but not necessarily hand this
genetic modification and sort of genes
have got a bad press you know Hitler
like gene so we should be against them
but Hitler he also was a vegetarian and
he liked dogs so you know if should you
reject dogs because Hitler was a light
dog so obviously the answer isn't you
know just because Hitler was for
something he doesn't mean we have to be
against it
so that's sort of my statement i guess
it's best if you I'll try and respond to
any question yes I I have not read the
double helix yet so when I do read it
I'm curious can you tell me now some
additional insight that the author can
give me something maybe you wish you'd
done a little differently or written
more about no I'm very okay with every
every word you know I wouldn't change it
it was written as a there's a sort of
nonfiction novel I want to read it like
a novel am so it wasn't written looking
back you know it was just you know on
that day that was sort of my memory of
it or it should have happened that way
and you know then I changed you know my
opinion so some people as a student as a
book but I'm so yeah I was my attempt to
show you know what my personality is
like in what I liked it
so someone had the good sense after was
the woman who worked for Harvard
University Press which initially was
going to publish it we said you know I
should really say something about the
people afterwards was let me you know
look at rosslyn frankly than a more for
view I said she was very good scientist
but and you know that she prematurely
died of cancer so but I didn't sure and
then a successor which can much later
jeans girls and gallop I tried to write
that the same way a series of feminist
writers upset by the use of girls than
the title you know wanted me to be
something more than a cowl 25 year old
but that's what I was so I was trying to
you know to express see you know what it
was like to be 25 double helix went
between 23 and 25 yes engineered food
issue I understand you recently we're on
a speaking tour in Europe could you
comment on the near phobia that many
Europeans seem to have about the
genetically
no I is complicated a lot of reasons
some people are uncomfortable with
science you know Greenpeace has to have
something dad cheated again and it was
probably a wise for Monsanto to try and
you know move around the world instead
of licensing the technology to local
French firm sir we're not be perceived
as America trying to own the world's
food supply and so we explain this in
the books about 40 years ago I was
chairman of President Kennedy's
committee of the boll weevil and which
followed my membership in the Committee
on pesticide so and before that I you
know biological and chemical warfare so
for a couple years I dealt with poisons
and so when it was possible you know to
make a plant which could kill insects
you know through something inside the
plant rather than having to apply poison
I thought it's going to be a lot safer
for farmers so you know
it's been very bad the Sheep cause of
poisoning in England I think it's just
agricultural chemicals so we should try
and reduce their use of genetically
modified plants as way of reducing their
use but you know the daily mail came out
against the Prince Charles and then the
French just you know sometimes you know
don't want to accept american way of
life mcdonalds sound so it was
complicated now plus you know you know
Hitler wanted to use jeans therefore you
know it goes back to it it's rather a
fan of tragedy for those sort of plant
scientists in England who had a really
very good science and then suddenly they
didn't have anything to do because what
they were doing couldn't be used so I
think nations which don't use now I
don't suffer so you know the Chinese are
going full blast on and you know so your
PO have to accept it i've been to be the
only part in the world monsanto sales
are going up this year you know the
farmer is like you know if you believe
in Liberty let the farmers by what they
think is good for so many ways
I know Sierra Club was against
recombinant DNA hi this you know why
should they be against it but they were
so I had a Washington Post leader
against Robert Redford for supporting
the Sierra Club so yeah yeah you know
see our club sounds good but cheers
about waiver yeah I think they're just
as bad as the old on American Activities
yep what is your thinking about the
theory of complexity I don't think about
at all yeah I just try and thinking
about simple sex as opposed to
reductionism oh I'm a complete
reductionist I'll are you whatever you
working you believe in the theory of
complexity or not that then I don't know
what it is so I mean some things are so
complex that you know you can't
understand them you know you know like
economics or something so stay away but
you know I mean reduction it just means
you know you're trying to you know under
reduce things from you know the laws of
physics or chemistry or Mendelian laws
you know what else is there besides
reductionism there is no there's
revelation and you know or stay away
from revelation and you know so your
observation experiments to me you know
that's how you sort of and you know
that's coupled to you know some
instinctive reactions like supposedly we
you know don't like snakes and things
like that you're on more positive you
know so our life is
you know we use reason whenever we can
but if you know sometimes runs up
against your emotions yes do you have a
religious absolutely not even a luckiest
thing that ever happened to me was they
have a father didn't believe in God so
you know I just my life wasn't held back
yeah you know you know truth by
revelation you know it's really you know
so you know I've never had the desire to
kill for God yeah I know it's just you
know we're supposed to think you know be
very tolerant of religion but you know
and say that it doesn't conflict with
science but you know if to the extent it
says you know you know that every word
in the Bible is correct you know that
obviously conflicts with science so
that's about all I can say I could say
that makes me reduction as I have no
spiritual thoughts but you know I
casually even like a dog you know even
though you know since ever since one bit
me early in life I've been suspicious
yes sir francis oh yeah no I yes I mean
his interest says you're on something I
can't understand which is you how the
brain works and my interest to stay
pretty DNA centered and you know what
cancer is or mental disease so fans has
sort of moved away from the DNA world
and
as he's not an experimentalist it
doesn't like to you know be the boss of
anyone is it a theoretician the brain is
a good thing you know he's had a very
good life and he's been a very positive
influence i think in neurologic yes
voted you were opposed to the genome
project i was what you were opposed to
genome project MOS I helped start it and
I was fired as the head of it by
Bernadine Healy but you know how was it
with it oh I mean it's a tremendous
accomplishment I mean you know it's your
instruction book and we're trying to
read it I mean sometimes you know you
don't know whether you want to read it
because you know give hints as to your
life span and things like that but i
think the the knowledge of it is bound
to improve human life yes what are your
thoughts on human cloning especially as
it applies to medical breakthroughs well
there's a therapeutic cloning you know
do should you do work on stem cells i
think obviously yes is that you know i
don't think there's anything you know
spiritual will bother stem cell and yeah
i don't know who i'm attending way right
now those people who seriously sort of
studied you know cloning of animals
they're they're not quite normal so I
don't think it would you know fear to
bring into a child as a clone you know
any more than my mother should you know
be a heavy alcoholic but because that
child is going to be damaged so it'd be
irresponsible i think they've got was
ever a couple of days ago you know if
someone seriously been trying to clone
primates with no luck whatsoever and
they think they may you know by doing it
in a different way maybe succeed I sort
of hope it won't because I think we'll
always have the problem what if someone
wants to make 50 identical copies of
some on them that is that's not going to
be very nice I think I had a you know
really letter for a woman who you know
Wanda cloner mother and so you know what
can you say so you know I wrote back
your mother must have been very nice but
but you know for any woman to want to
clone herself I think that would be
pretty not a nice gift to her daughter
because you know anyone's gonna marry
the daughter well you know realize she's
going to look like the mother and you
know you rather not know that so yeah
but on the other hand you know if you
could say well you know the you can't
have a child and you know would you like
to have someone who's gonna sort of look
are we short you know something so it
looks all right hand uh you know isn't
gonna be schizophrenic or diabetic or
something like that you could say that's
better than you know just maybe you know
adopting a child who was put up for
adoption because they're schizophrenia
so you know you just might say this in
my self-interest to have a clone if you
know is going to be good but I sort of
hope and still hope it won't happen and
but it won't be the end of the world no
really won't go as you know you might
want to say will ban identical clones
well yeah I mean twins but you know they
get yeah yes my understanding is the the
great value of cloning for people is is
not to give yourself identical twins but
to give yourself a replacement organs in
case of organ failure but I wouldn't
want to be born for that reason yeah
good could we talk about something else
oh yeah I mean I'm you know there are a
lot of things which you know might
happen within my lifetime I don't think
clothing is going to be
you know a large number of identical
looking people could be bad for law
enforcement yeah so you know I quite
willing to have a law against doing that
so but something egomaniac you know
might wanna no do it and I'm sort of
feeling worried about it after it
happens because you know unless you stop
in vitro fertilization clinics you know
and just make the technology really very
hard to get it someone can play that
game but that you know that would never
take away you know the freedom of some
women who can't have children to have
children so you know I'd rather go for
the immediate good that worried about
you know the harm was you know I mean
you know these pretty scary to have an
identical copies of our president yeah
you know you know I'm react to him like
some people who reacted Bill Clinton but
you know that's just your political
prejudice so yeah tough you know that's
yeah biotechnology right now are things
like cloning in tissue engineering no
not coming and I think poor front of you
know really practical we want to get
drugs which will stop mental disease and
whether my question is what do you
imagine 20 years from now 50 years show
that's too far to think ahead you don't
just sit and wonder no no pretty thing
he had 20 years is never you know very
useful you know you can say in 10 years
maybe that's something 10 years well we
might have some good drugs who gets
cancer well you know you might get that
under
I don't think we can get mental disease
under control that we don't know enough
about you know we've been learning an
immense amount of about cancer so we
know what we're we sort of know where we
should go sort of how we should go there
so most of you know the knowledge using
DNA will come because most of the
relevant facts have been learned in the
last 20 years and it takes that sort of
long and often together in the medical
practice
you follow all the DNA news the Clinton
thing in the oj simpson thing and the
death row prisoners who get released him
and these soldiers in the Gulf War who
carry do you follow it and you get a
kick out of it because you're the
kick-out movie the wrong word right I
mean certainly the people have been
released from prison movement falsely
incarcerated that has to be very
pleasing I these most pleasing to alex
jeffreys who invented the technology you
know he wreath ate it I was a big big
step forward I mean visual
identification sticks and so many people
are convicted on the basis of visual
identification so if you can use DNA
evidence justice whole people you know
she'll be just instead of unjust yes
I follow up on we just had a couple of
minutes ago about lots of other things
will happen within your lifetime I'd
like you know what you foresee well I
want to see cancer stuff yeah I've been
as the major focus of the Cold Spring
Harbor lab for 35 years oh yeah I think
that's the sort of achievable dream yeah
oh yeah yeah you might as well hain big
yeah yes now have very specific
treatments do you think the cure for
cancer is going to be the one well the
only general one would be to stop its
blood vessels from your growing into a
sort of [ __ ] thing that hasn't been
really tested yet that some of the
proteins might be non-toxic and i really
like molecules which you know will make
you think slower
and you know they could really be you
know penicillin my things there are some
markers good ones probably being
developed that will be you know have
real toxicity so but yeah I know all I
maybe I'm optimistic we're gonna catch
somewhere yes how does it feel to be
immortalized in science textbooks
throughout the world I think you don't
think about it you know no you know I
don't feel one more you know it would be
a more satisfying for you so if we
hadn't found the DNA structure someone
else would have so yeah the long-term
you know I'd rather you know we yeah I
could be known for those you know is a
good writer that's slightly more unique
oh I can yes yes if you could be any one
of Shakespeare's characters who would
you be I'm not sure I don't know it well
not obviously they wouldn't want to be
Hamlet and I wouldn't want to be Macbeth
them you know not King Lear or so so I'm
not sure I really would yeah yeah I've
seen myself I've never seen myself as a
Shakespearean where's what here I see
myself you know more is a Turgenev
character or something not those to ask
me not him II well you know yeah mmm yes
I was wondering with emerging
technologies and with the rise of
bioinformatics what you see some of the
major changing trends in molecular
biology methodologies to be
yeah the genomic thing means you know
that you got a it's helped if you can
get genomics level it's going to be hard
not to be associated with a big place
and so you've gotta somehow yeah if I
were young I would try and go to
something slightly at the frontier and
bioinformatics doesn't strike me as a
frontier anymore yeah I would try and go
to genetics of behavior you're not
trying to which the interest me you know
it's how how can be behavior be a coded
by James and you know it seems very
mysterious and almost impossible but you
know and how baby walks when she does
you know let's not talk by its mother
but on the other hand we're not going to
find out so you gotta go to a much
simpler animal probably to get to
profound answer strengthen you know
we're not going to find out how the
Golden Plover navigates you know that
was one of my ambitions when I was young
that might be still 100 years off yes
yeah at the end of the nature paper
there's a statement discussing how the
structure of DNA might relate to its
replicating the ability for replicate
some curious what were the ideas that
you had at the time and
the end of meshing though well we murder
mom fight you know five weeks later our
ideas appeared you know there's the
strands separate but you know we could
have written a paragraph or we could
have written a sentence somehow was a
compromise between my thinking it was so
obvious we didn't have to say it in
Francis saying if we don't say it
someone else will claim credit for so we
have a dump with that sentence I was
probably a pain in the ass sort of
perversity of youth yes since the
smallpox genome is in the open
literature how likely is it that
terrorists could you reconstruct a small
box from them now i am very unlikely
yeah you just get some smallpox so you
would reconstruct it yeah I mean you
could put it together but you know if
you want to be you know you know really
cause harm I wouldn't do it that way
yes yeah sure right here further I was
just curious if you were a student now
would you want to study proteins as
opposed to DNA no no I'm really I mean
you get to protein fridge you know I'd
really like to know how behavior is
controlled that's finally the gene
instead of course that teach you to
obviously most genes probably not
specify the structure of a protein so
you know you get two proteins but yeah I
sort of proteins are for chemists you
know we've given could be addressed in
chemistry whereas I'm sort of you know
initially I was sort of you know
naturalist and so you know i keep going
back in that church
yes the pursuit of medicine or practical
or actually
the pursuit of knowledge that if driven
your study oh well when you're young you
don't think about medicine that's you
know when you're old do you know you
know you can't eat listen to the evening
news without those goddamn love you know
advertisements for medicine so it just
reflects it you know yeah you know
what's the best tranquilizer what's the
best allergy that you know that way
which just reflects life so as you get
older sure you want medicine i'm
interested in finding drugs which will
stop cancer so very medically oriented
but I wouldn't if I were you I wouldn't
or urge someone to yeah have the fun of
the lease for a while not thinking about
your prostate
yeah half dozen but they got something
you know yeah i mean the evening news
you know is really grim and the nature
of the advertisements you know we didn't
used to have the drug companies
advertising at night but now you're
seeing Bob dough or something like that
you know yeah I'd rather not yes be
writing a book they'll have a chapter
about accepting a Nobel Prize and how to
do that could you just talk about that
experience and what it was like well
yeah I didn't know you know I thought
it'd be you know having seen a Roman
Holiday it would be nice to marry a
princess and you know so I met one and
yeah but you know it would have been a
very boring marriage yeah she's nice but
you know I could never learn how to
speak Swedish oh I don't want to learn
how to speak Swedish you know and you
know I'd had to be more respectable yeah
it's not a good buy yeah it was it'll be
it's you know the ultimate sort of
objective you know if you're an
intellectual and it was nice to get it
and but you know it can't be your
objective for your you know when you're
young
you know I just wanted to do good
science that we never expected to find
something is wonderful so double things
you know when we saw it was just just so
much better than yeah the effort to it
into finding which it really wasn't that
yeah yeah
if as an elementary school teacher I'd
like to know if there's anything that
you remember from your school days that
early that got you interested in science
no it wasn't certainly and you know my
teachers in high school where you got a
little science now I think you get a
lower lip you know encourage me you know
all I teach are always like someone who
likes their subject so you know
generally you know p you know devote
attention to people who like your
subject rather than trying to get
someone interested in science and you
just thinking about the guitar and you
know it's impossible though you know
yeah I don't think I'm zipper teacher's
pet or something you know terrible word
but you know it's better to be a
teacher's pet than you know you know
that someone was being you know about to
be thrown out of school you know because
of you yeah but yeah I yeah on the whole
I much preferred mighty well not at all
but your teachers then your classmates
yeah you know because they knew Morgan
you and you know i was really wanting
meet people from whom I could learn and
you know I was off his lot of killed her
I never tried to please my plaque at
classmates my sister did you know and
she always thought I was gonna get into
trouble because I seem to
not care well I was popular so I think
trying to be popular that's terrible
when kids just you know fraternity yeah
you know I really my friends were books
when I was shot yeah books I can learn
from and so I think a reverence for
books is you can somehow get your kids
like books and they really can be broad
yes the difference between the genetic
structure of human being and chimpanzees
supposed to be less than half less than
one percent well no its you know the
same genes and they're expressed a
slightly different time so it's going to
be we're going to learn a lot by
studying you know how to count for the
great differences David you know we can
write it right up yes yes and some
others we got a better brain and we're a
little less violent yeah so you know the
the better brain with violence would is
which may have been the Neanderthals had
a bigger brain than we did and so
necessarily you've gotta somehow
restrained male violence on the other
hand you know being like the bonobo
would be a disaster that it never led to
a bookstore or cathedral or what just
sex so that's not an evolutionary path
which you know I think
yeah I just like seeing new things and
you know creative things and so you know
in achieving this you you've got to have
you know a certain ability to to be
different produce a product is different
but that's going to upset someone might
different that makes all the difference
so you know I think you
you
you know I just wanted to you know
basically you know produce something you
know better improve things enhance life
you know and
yeah I think you know well you know
whatever my nature is you know I've been
curious and you know there one time you
either say I think we're born with you
know basically more good than bad and we
really want a our fellow human beings
that you know have better life so that
sort of been a driving force for me you
know what I was young I thought it meant
you had to be a Democrat but you know
I'm les you know I'm not so dogmatic you
know like difference yeah I see the
difference now not between you know the
rich and the poor but between the the
secular and the religious I think that's
going to be the big tension in your life
in future you know because one wants to
you know make you work for God and the
other is you know you gotta somehow
challenge people working for themselves
in a way that doesn't you know set back
the life of others
this
didn't really want to look into the
future so I'd like to ask you to kind of
take a step back the last 50 years and
see if you
mentioned three techniques there are too
many discoveries that you think that
yourself marvel at after that foundation
work gets you the doctor cricket well
you know polymerase PCR polymerase chain
reaction boy that was pretty good and so
techniques you know that let you now DNA
chips are you know great now there's
RNAi I mean there are a lot of things
depending you know on what you ended
science moves forward a lot of
technology development you got to have a
you know x-ray beam you know the DNA
sequencing technology improved by a
factor of about a thousand so that's the
reason you can think about general
sequencing your dog or dog you know
you know what's a fundamental difference
between a dog in a Wolf yeah I'd like to
find out so there's so many things now
that I think we can get answers to it
you know and people are really very
curious about themselves and now with
even Gina where begin to understand you
know human differences we all want to do
that okay I think maybe I'll sign hooks
James Watson is author of DNA the secret
of life it's published by Knopf a
division of Random House visit Random
House calm / Knopf for more information